[Music]
professor fucano the famous eccentric
scientist and adventurer has embarked on
a new challenge flying around the world
non-stop in a plane of his own design
able to travel consistently at the
incredible speed of one degree longitude
around the equator per minute the plane
would take six hours to circle the world
there's just one problem the plane can
only hold 180 kiloliters of fuel only
enough for exactly half the journey
let's be honest the professor probably
could have designed the plane to hold
more fuel but where's the fun in that
instead he's devised a slightly more
elaborate solution
building three identical planes for the
mission
in addition to their speed the
professors equipped them with a few
other incredible features each of the
planes can turn on a dime and instantly
transfer any amount of its fuel to any
of the others in mid-air without slowing
down provided they're next to each other
the professor will pilot the first plane
while his two assistants fugori and
orokana will pilot each of the others
however only one airport located on the
equator has granted permission for the
experiment making it the starting point
the finish line and the only spot where
the planes can land take off or refuel
on the ground
how should the three planes coordinate
so the professor can fly continuously
for the whole trip and achieve his dream
without anyone running out of fuel and
crashing
according to the professor's
calculations they should be able to pull
it off by a hair
the key is to maximize the support each
assistant provides not wasting a single
kiloliter of fuel
it also helps us to think symmetrically
so they can make shorter trips in either
direction while setting the professor up
for a long unsupported stretch in the
middle here's his solution
all three planes take off at noon flying
west each fully loaded with a 180
kiloliters
after 45 minutes or 1 8 of the way
around each plane has
kiloliters left odokana gives 45 to the
professor and 45 to fugori
fully refueling them both
with her remaining 45 orokana returns to
the airport and heads to the lounge for
a well-deserved break
45 minutes later with one quarter of the
trip complete the professor and fugori
are both at 135 kiloliters again
fugori transfers 45 into the professor's
tank leaving himself with the 90 he
needs to return
professor fukano stretches and puts on
his favorite album he'll be alone for a
while
in the meantime odokana has been
anxiously awaiting fugori's return her
plane fully refueled and ready to go
as soon as his plane touches the ground
she takes off this time flying east
at this point exactly 180 minutes have
passed and the professor is at the
halfway point of his journey with 90
kiloliters of fuel left
for the next 90 minutes the professor
and otokana's planes fly towards each
other meeting at the three-quarter mark
just as the professor's fuel is about to
run out he sees oricana's plane she
gives him 45 kiloliters of her remaining
90 leaving them with 45 each
but that's just half of what they need
to make it to the airport
fortunately this is exactly when fugori
having refueled takes off
45 minutes later just as the other two
planes are about to run empty he meets
them at the 315 degree point and
transfers 45 kiloliters of fuel to each
leaving 45 for himself
all three planes land at the airport
just as their fuel gauges reach zero
as the reporters and photographers cheer
the professor promises his planes will
soon be available for commercial flights
just as soon as they figure out how to
keep their in-flight meals from spilling
everywhere
[Music]
you